chaque samedi soir nous proposons à deux
volontaires d'échanger leur métier le
temps d'une journée ce soir un tapissier
va devenir traiteur et inversement
échange standard supervisé par arnaud
lefebvre
isabelle rivière et pascal di betta plat
du jour ou plats de fêtes savez vous
planter des clous à la mode de chez nous
ils sont presque voisin avenue du
drapeau
mais aujourd'hui ils vont devoir porter
l'étendard du métier d'à côté
bonjour brice aujourd'hui chez les fous
la première chose c'est mieux de la rai
déguisé donc c'est le tablier du
débutant alors ils te laissent
l'ajustage de mots comme ça je peux
savoir la preuve on n'a pas d'effet ne
cessa la rue du dr métier aujourd'hui
oui on va faire des gougères alliés
ouais aïe
on est en bourgogne c'est l'occasion ou
jamais et tu sais ce qu'on y fier d'être
bourguignon fin tu connais je pense que
tu as fais là là là aussi c'est le
moment ou jamais tu vois ça c'est la
recette initiale passée enfin j'étais
tout jeune donc celui ci l'a il a
d'histoire donc je te demandais
décrocher une casserole s'il te plaît tu
peux me dire qu'est ce qui te plaît
havas est digne où ça fait une écurie
forêt
as tu vois sa selle son sel sont plus
vieille que moi celle ci tu vois donc on
a pesé les 500 grammes d'eau à yoff g
ration de risquer ma vie
on est les seuls à sel et le sucre quand
même il ya du sel et du sucre donc un
moitié de sucre le sel va porter le le
goût bien sûr et le sucre va donner une
jolie petite coloration et puis le
beurre donc on a coupé en petits
morceaux
donc on va laisser tranquillement tu vas
attendre que ton mélange monte comme les
rats comme il en train de le faire et tu
verses la farine en pluie tout en
remuant au pur et allez ça commence à se
corser à monsieur verviétois vas-y
franchement
[Musique]
donc je vais demander de me casser les
oeufs oui je les mets à part un impact
voilà et si tu lui mets tout son sens en
bas c'est la catastrophe
je te laisse à incorporer le deuxième on
va essayer
ça fait les bras c'est ça
[Musique]
elle tient bien c'est parfait
alors là c'est là ne ressemble à rien en
même temps une gauchère qui ressemble à
rien on voit qu'elle est artisanal
matrice il a une exigence coiffé de
professionnels donc c'est un animal qui
tremble franchement il m'a même un peu
et pâté au niveau du couchage des
gougères parce que je m'étais dit on va
le mettre un petit peu en difficulté on
pourra se moquer un petit peu finalement
il s'en est super bien sorti tu as senti
l'odeur set up a quand même
alors là tu m'as dit il fallait que je
tape de soit la seule c'est pas mal du
tout pour un petit jeune qui démarre
dans super messieurs je crois que c'est
ce qui s'appelle arrivé au bon moment
pour et dégustation brice il est temps
de rendre le tablier au sens premier du
terme
direction l'atelier
branchée
frais douche de suite voilà ce que je te
propose je t'écoute essaie de faire la
couverture avec ce joli petit tissu tu
voit orange de ce petit tabouret louis
15 alors d'abord on va utiliser ces
petits coups là qu'on appelle des
semences qui vont nous servir à pointer
le tissu pour le mettre en place
y a pas de risque déchirement après si
tu arrives à déchirer du tissu
d'ameublement à la main faut inscrire
cher les deux russes d'accord et on va
utiliser un pied-de-biche
c'est une petite biche oui petite ville
justifiée mais efficace je crois outils
symbolique du tapissier qu'est le
ramponneau le rampeau nous oui
donc on va commencer par placer tu vois
le milieu de tant tissus au milieu de
son siège tu vises là où tu veux mettre
à semences tu tape un petit coup sec
deux petits coups histoire que ça tienne
et la tonte issue il est à pointer donc
tu vas faire la même chose de l'autre
côté je suis pas au bon endroit je crois
pas là je pense que dans la garniture
accord pour un peu trop alors là je suis
un petit peu trop bas cette fois la tête
du pied là par exemple n'est pas dans le
décor n'a pas cassé la fleurette
ah oui en effet oui ça fait un trou
comme ça ça fait un petit trou on peut
dire que c'est authentique quelques que
le bois et ses langes et par les animaux
aient ou non fait on a toujours un peu
peur de tirer en fait pour ça pour
t'aider voilà je vois 7/4 et cela elles
permettent à huy bondissant sur la
longueur il faut de la force au bout des
doigts il faut là
souplesse dans la main pour bien tirer
le tissu bien et beaucoup de ressenti en
fait sur le bout des doigts et c'est
très très compliqué très appliqués
patients rigoureux on sent quelqu'un qui
aime travailler qui aime être dans le
geste parfaite je suis tendu l'influent
bien commun en ring très bien connu un
petit coup encore pour que ça rentre un
peu plus
voilà l'idée c'est qu'on va avancer on
va mettre un coup là un coup là un clou
la tac tac tac tac tac partie mecs tu as
les micros
les deux petits copeaux voit la chanson
mais si j'allais l'appeler petits clous
des p'tits clous toujours délicat on va
s'arrêter là pense à toi merci doit
participer à l'expérience et on termine
n'a pas la tradition la petite photo
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]